[Music]
welcome hi hope you are having good time
in the conference or while learning from
each other
it's exciting to me and talk to you you
know through the booths and one-on-one
events you know learning about new use
cases and new framing of problems every
day I am Raja Logan Aden I'm an
engineering manager with Google Cloud
storage
I have Sebastian Frank from Google cloud
as well we also have Sai from one of our
storage partners capacity today I would
like to talk about building systems that
are security by design and default using
Google Cloud Storage we work with a lot
of customers from different market
segments so I'd like to take some time
to talk about the industry trend that we
see with security and storage one of the
main theme that you have been hearing
through this conference is how cloud is
democratizing the special powers for
engineers and our industry you don't
have to be one of those few companies in
the world who get to use a storage
system with 11 nines of durability
irrespective whether you're a start-up
or a big enterprise company you have
access to such a storage system if
that's what you need to make your
business successful so today let's
explore this theme little bit more in
the context of security and scalability
to make my case I would like to start
off with an analogy as many of you might
know this is Jacques Cousteau he
pioneered the modern day marine
conservation he has traveled to the
remote corners of the earth to study
coral reef system and other sea life and
in order to be underwater eco developed
the first open circuit breathing
apparatus that evolved into the modern
day regulators yes had a tremendous
influence in this field well thanks to
his influence I picked up diving as my
hobby and you know diving took me to
different parts of the world
here is a map of many of the coral reefs
where I've spent days diving many of
these reefs are in pristine condition
teeming with life now let me step back
iron out to be a jack westcoast or a
full-time arraigned researcher to
experience these amazing sights and will
that sense of appreciation what is
making it possible for a common man like
me number one we have resilient
regulators they are robos that I can put
it in my garage and I can use it when I
need it number two no matter which
corner of the earth I go there are
universal safety standards even in
today's world diving can be pretty
dangerous if not for those safety
standards number three this is more
important we have reached a critical
mass of community to support diving when
you think about our industry we have a
similar trend going on you have access
to a planet scale blob storage system
and as I've been saying it provides 11
lines of durability whether you want to
store your few MB photo or if you are an
animation movie studio wanting to store
terabytes elf movie file you can store
it here you can store exabytes of data
if you are thinking about cost we have a
range of option from article storage if
you're streaming music the time to first
byte is going to be in milliseconds and
even if it is a cold storage the
response time is going to be in
milliseconds as opposed to hours or days
here are some of our customers on how
they use Google Cloud Storage customers
use multi regional option for content
storage and delivery and customers go
with big date the regional option for
big data analytics and customers use
near line or cold line for backup
archival purposes we also have storage
partners such as callosity who offer
Google Cloud Storage as one of the
options let me go back to the
scalability theme when you're thinking
about the Theory of Constraints for your
business you are no longer worried about
building some complex distributed system
now the focus has shifted to our
detecting the right system for your
business so let me ask all of you a
question
for the systems that you are running for
your business from a scalability
standpoint what are the trade-offs
you're making what failure modes are you
worried about what bottlenecks are you
worried about now I know most of you are
going to give me a good set of answers
because as an industry we have done an
effective job in disseminating
scalability patterns and thanks to cloud
the cognitive load to think about these
patterns are also substantially less now
start thinking about security I will get
to it in a second we are seeing example
where within a company two teams going
with completely different architecture
with different storage solution this was
almost unimaginable 10 15 years within
your organization pick one storage
solution or the other
effectively our organization and our
systems are becoming a starfish starfish
has this interesting neural structure
where if it loses an arm it's going to
regrow it in fact starfish can shed an
arm as a defense mechanism because it
knows it can regrow so what about
security with security what we are
saying is we are still stuck in the
traditional model of having a single
watchdog team for your entire
organization with the pace of innovation
the velocity of changes that are going
on and the sheer complexity of the
systems that you're running by the way
the complexity is not going to go down
having this traditional model is just
not scalable our organizations and our
systems how to become a starfish from a
security standpoint as well we have to
emulate the success that we have created
with scalability security is the new
scalability so in order to effectively
disseminate security ideas patterns are
a very good mechanism for you to have
good conversations with your team to
make intentional choices and will
security at every layer so in the next
few slides let's talk about some of the
security part
that we commonly see among our customers
the first thing with security is people
when you're thinking of scalability we
mostly think in terms of systems but
with security people play an equal role
as I've been saying with the growing
complexity there are often interesting
interplay between people and system so
for you to have good security you know
there has to be intentional architecting
for people and system to talk about the
next couple of pattern let me set up a
scenario let's say you're a financial
company with multiple research teams
let's say these research teams are
operating on a common data set the data
set is particularly not sensitive let's
say it's a public data set but the
results being produced by your research
team is what is providing you the
competitive advantage in the market they
are extremely sensitive that you don't
even want to share among other teams and
let's say you also have a team of
analysts you are looking at these
results to make decisions on behalf of
your business
so using that scenario let's talk about
this first pattern this is the confused
fut pattern this is the case when there
is ambiguous definition of
responsibility or authority
so in our scenario let's say the
researcher found some interesting
results and want to share with this team
you can go to our Google Cloud storage
console and hit that share publicly
button to provide reader access to his
team but that action is not only
providing reader access to this
organization or a steam he is providing
reader access to the entire public
Internet so this this is not even a bad
actor scenario this is good actor with
good intentions but still the
consequences are not what you desire by
the way we are revamping this console
experience to to make it better so to
tactically solve that problem the first
thing you have to take care is you have
to like define the roles here we have
predefined roles for example in this
scenario for the researcher maybe you
can go with a creator role where they
can create objects but not necessarily
modify permission
you're not happy with the predefined
rules we have I am custom rules that you
can create with customized set of
permissions but still this is to context
show to tactical
there are a lot of storage permissions
as you can see here so is there a way to
solve this problem at a higher
granularity so let's talk about this
next pattern privilege separation
pattern let's say you're using Google
cameras to encrypt data in cloud storage
now you have two sets of formations that
you can operate with for example
analysts at a higher granularity can
think about which projects are which
access so now no matter what the storage
permissions are people cannot read the
object without the decrypt permission
let's zoom out even further if you set
up a virtual private network across your
resources in Google cloud across your
buckets objects Google compute engine
and other other services
now irrespective of any permission none
of the data is going to get out of that
parameter that you have set up all right
let's switch gear let's talk about some
encryption patterns the first one is the
key wrapping pattern this is super
useful to solve encryption problem at
scale and to solve problem like zero an
organization for sensitive information
such as credit card number to illustrate
this example I would like to use an
example from within our system on how we
use this pattern inside of Google Cloud
Storage let's say you scheme is to store
an object in in our service when we get
the object the first thing we do is
chunk them this is to make sure we use
our own infrastructure effectively the
name approach here is going to be take
all of those chunks send it over to kms
get it encrypted get it back and then
store them it is pretty ineffective
because of the data are going all around
and from a performance profile it's not
going to be acceptable for you instead
what we do is
we generate a local encryption key for
each one of those chunks and then after
encrypting the chunks we take those
local encryption key send it over to kms
get it encrypted get it back and then
store it in our system which effectively
achieves the same purpose you could also
use this example for the zero
anonymization let's say you're storing
files in cloud storage with sensitive
information such as social security
number credit card number instead of
sending the whole file over to canvas
you could use the local encryption key
to anonymize those information and then
send that local key to over to KMS get
it encrypted okay let's talk about this
next pattern crypto shredding pattern in
order to provide the best possible
customer experience you are trying to
solve all kinds of cool problems for
your customers let's say you take the
data stored in your bucket move it to
bigquery to do some analytics then take
the data further to do some more
analysis to provide that additional
value for your customer but what is
happening is the customer data is
getting proliferated when the time comes
to delete deletion you want to
effectively delete the entire footprint
to maintain trust with your customer and
sometimes to meet regulations like GD P
R so in such scenarios this pattern
could potentially be useful let's say
you're using Google kms you can use a
same key across different Google
services now as soon as you get rid of
the key then all of the data or
effectively meaningless and then you can
go around cleaning them up later but
from a customer point of view you have
you know effectively deleted the data we
are after similar approach within Google
Cloud Storage to the first thing we
focus on is getting rid of those
encryption keys to make all of those
chunks meaningless and then we go to the
garbage collection the last pattern I
want to talk about is the privilege
revocation pattern in the previous
pattern we talked about how to
effectively delete the data in this
pattern let's talk about how to
effectively not delete the data
I'm not joking here there are valid
scenarios let's say you're a financial
industry then you are required to keep
some data for X number of years in those
cases you can basically revoke access
from a deletion standpoint and then no
matter who you are in your organization
you can't delete the data Google cloud
will keep it for the X number of years
that you have specified and then it will
open up the access back to you so that
you can delete it by the way that image
over there is not a jail before your
imaginations run wild
that's Fort Knox where the gold is
stored next I would like to invite
swashes to talk about the GCSE security
primitives that you get security is the
new scalability security something which
is at the heart of our design as far as
GCSE in particular and Google Cloud
Storage and Google cloud platform in
general is concerned security is not
something that we think of something
that can be an afterthought that you can
bolt on later it is something that you
have to plan for and design at every
layer of your stack so when our users
use Google Cloud storage or in general
when they use Google cloud there are
lots of special powers with regards to
security that they get right so
according to third-party estimates
Google's
private network is probably the largest
private network out there in the world
it has thousands of edge nodes it has
hundreds of pop nodes you know as a
customer you are never too far away from
a Google point of presence now this is a
tremendous security advantage for our
customers as well right so what happens
is say your data is stored in a
particular region but you are accessing
the data from a different city or you
are writing to the data from a different
city now with any other cloud storage
provider out there what would happen is
the data would take the public Internet
to the region where the data is stored
with GCS so what happens is we actually
get your data through the nearest pop so
say if you are writing from New York
City we will actually
the data into Google's private network
through the pop in New York City and you
might be actually writing your data to
Europe right so this has tremendous
benefits in terms of performance it has
tremendous benefits in terms of cost
because you are not paying interest
charges you know for public internet
traversal but most importantly this has
also tremendous benefit in terms of
security because what happens is your
data is traversing through the private
network of Google for as much time as
possible thereby minimizing exposure in
public Internet
right now encryption is something which
is at the core of security
considerations as well right so with GCS
all your data is always encrypted we
have multi layer of multiple layers of
encryption for GCS data your data is
encrypted at the data layer it is
encrypted at the storage and media layer
right there are some public cloud
storage providers with whom default
encryption is an option right we
fundamentally don't believe in that
personally speaking I find this sentence
where you have you know default
encryption option it seems to me an
oxymoronic statement right so we
fundamentally believe as a platform that
all your data should always be encrypted
right now encryption at rest is fine
what about encryption in flight all of
you GCS data is also encrypted in flight
the only exceptions we have are for
multi cloud use cases where you might be
writing to another cloud storage which
is not encrypted by default right for
example for s3 compatibility we do
support unencrypted modes of you know
data and data movement in flight but for
all of your native GCS data it is always
encrypted in flight now in addition to
encryption what is also very important
is how do you manage the encryption
right how do you actually manage the
keys which are encrypting your data so I
often talk to some customers from highly
regulated industries with a high
security sensitivity sensitivity they
say you know she washes everything you
say is great but I cannot really store
my encryption key with you
my dictates are such that I need to
store the encryption key on my premises
or on my HSM right so GCS allows for
that as
well you do not have to store it
encryption keys with us you just supply
to us during the time you write the data
or you read the data or you do any
metadata operation so we fully support
customer supplied encryption key as well
right so along with the encryption
another very key component of your
security considerations is auditing for
regulatory compliance auditing is very
important for even you forget regulatory
compliance even from your perspective if
you have to ensure things are working
the way they're supposed to and access
is the way it is you need to ensure that
you have solid audits in place right so
as a platform and as a product we
believe in giving you a lot of choice
right
so with GCS as far as auditing is
concerned you can go for multiple
options here you can go for cloud audit
logging which is a platform wide load
logging capability so whether it is
administrative activity or it is data
access or it logging you can get it
through cloud or data logging now if you
want to really dig deep and you want to
find out at a very fine granularity that
per object you know was the kind of
latency I'm getting what is the kind of
data storage patterns that I have or how
is my object lifecycle management
behaving per object level right if you
are interested in that kind of detail
then you can also go for GCS access and
storage logs and then finally from a
compliance and regulatory perspective if
you want to consume this logs and if you
want to pipe them into your you know
pipelines your audit systems deployment
architectures you can use tag driver
monitoring which gives you programmatic
access to this audit logging information
as well right so again in many
conversations when I travel across the
world and I speak to you know new
customers or prospects they ask me ok
sheesh all that is great but you know I
come from health care industry unless
you talk HIPAA unless you're HIPAA
compliant I can't really use you so not
only we are HIPAA compliant as you can
see we are a platform with rich third
party audits and certifications we are
associate employment we are ISO
compliant we are PCI a level 3 complaint
and we are FedRAMP ATO compliant as well
so we are an enterprise platform and we
take care of the fact
whatever level of auditing and
certification you need to be with us it
would be there so in today's world PII
or personally identifiable information
is a very important topic right now it's
very topical because it's very sensitive
in nature and it's the center stone so
PII or personally identifiable
information is the center stone for you
know around which a lot of regulations
such as GDP are is formulated right so
GDP is life even as we speak there are
several other regulations which are also
in the process of being formulated which
all center around how do you handle PII
right so in our platform we have data
loss prevention api's DLP which allows
you to effectively redact encrypt psuedo
and analyze and for you to get a very
good grip on how your PII is right so it
allows you to analyze your PII it allows
you to visualize your PII and affect you
know effectively manage your PII
so one use case one customer use case
that I share at that I can share with
you is the following so say you are a
financial organization or you are a bank
and you want to ingest your data into
GCS as a data Lake and you want to run
big data analytics and you want to
understand analytic patterns for your
data but the challenge that you face you
know working with the public cloud is
okay what do I do with my PII because
there might be so many credit card
information
you know first name last name email ID
age social security number and so on
right so this is where data comes into
place you ingest your data in GCS you
run DLP over it DLP completely pseudo
and analyzes redact all the data even if
you are and then you can actually go
ahead with bigquery and you can analyze
the data and when the time comes and you
want to pipe the data out of the system
and move it back to say on Prem you can
use DLP to encrypt data as it increases
the public cloud right so this allows
you to completely leverage the power of
Google Cloud and at the same time ensure
that you do not sacrifice or compromise
your PII at all so these are all the
existing special powers that Google
Cloud as a platform and
cloud storage as a product gives you but
that's not all we are here to speak
about today it gives me a lot of joy to
talk about the new features that we are
announcing here publicly today for the
whole last year or so our team has been
busy working with our customers to
closely understand the problems that
they face and really solve high-value
problems so that we can continue to work
effectively in this new world the first
feature I want to announce today is
access transparency with GCS this
integration is going general
availability and this should be
available for general public consumption
pretty soon maybe as soon as you know
this event is over maybe as soon as next
week
so with access transparency the main
problem that we are solving is if we
want to know who it is that has access
to your data so this who could be a
Googler who say ah sorry and you know
the SRA might have access to your data
because say a hurricane was headed
towards your data center or maybe you
raised a ticket and you said hey I want
you to move this data from this location
to that because this sets me up for
better performance now from a compliance
and regulatory perspective what you want
to have is a very clean you know trail
of who has accessed my data what is the
location from which this data has been
accessed who is this person
why has this person moved my data what
is the justification right so access
transparency gives you all this
information and it is also available
through stackdriver monitoring for you
to programmatically integrate with your
systems right the second feature that I
am announcing today is going GA and this
is again a feature which should be
available probably as soon as next week
we are actually in the process of
rolling out the GA changes for this is a
bunch of security and privacy UI
enhancements and to tell you the problem
why why we are doing this right so well
last year last year and a half across
different public cloud services we you
know we heard from our customers who are
using some other services they said that
one problem that they faced is they
didn't
having very good handle on what part of
the data is public and what part of
their data data such a private right so
inadvertently they ended up over
exposing their data and in some cases
they were taken hostage off because you
know the sharing model was not really
very safe
there are various solutions with Google
cloud platform that you don't run into
this kind of a problem like VPC is a
major step towards the direction but you
may say you know what VPC is a big
sledgehammer for me I don't want to use
VPC can you give me something simpler so
we are doing this UI enhancements where
in your GCS browser you can very clearly
see which of your buckets are public
which of your objects are public right
and like the confused aput deputy access
pattern that Roger mentioned where you
could be sharing the data publicly
thinking public means you know your
company publicly not public Internet so
with these new UI changes even if you
were under a wrong impression as to what
your blast radius was you can't really
do this because we now have a I am panel
based interaction and through this I am
panel based interaction you would be
setting permissions on your data sets so
there is absolutely no way in no way
that by accident or inadvertently you
would be sharing this data with public
Internet the third feature I'm
announcing today publicly is cloud kms
some of you some of DCs customers are
actually testing this even as we speak
because this is in public beta what
cloud camus gives is you know to
describe what is the common problem that
we hear from our customers is they want
fine granular access to or they want
find regular manageability of their keys
like I should be able to create my key
delete my key rotate my key I should be
able to set automatic rotation schedule
for my key I should be able to disable
the key and so on but the main challenge
they face is hosting a key management
service ensuring the B key management
service is always on is very highly
available it can be very challenging
like what happens due to a hardware
failure or due to
you actually lose a key an encryption
key you might actually lose access to
petabytes of information right so what
cloud cam has does for you is cloud with
cloud cam as Google hosts the key for
you
Google ensures that the keys always
available for even every single region
with the latency and availability that
you want but you still retain all the
ability to have very fine granular
management for your encryption keys and
with this Decius integration you get the
same SLA in terms of availability and
durability and performance that is there
with Jesus even if you did not use cloud
cameras because I say as I said all the
time GCS is always encrypted either you
use cloud cameras and manage the keys
yourself or Google would automatically
manage it for you right so cloud kms is
in public beta right now I invite you
guys to actually test it out and as with
all the other features cloud camus is
also available programmatically now we
briefly alluded to V PC before V PC was
a very highly requested feature for
quite a long time a lot of customers
were used to sharing patterns and you
know Network firewalls in their private
infrastructure but the challenge with
public cloud there faced is the moment
they come to public cloud their existing
sharing patterns may be a little riskier
right so what V PC allows you to do is
to have a network firewall and for you
to have an environment where as if you
have your own private cloud within
public cloud right so if you PC you can
say okay this is my security access zone
this is my secure access zone rather and
in this secure exit zone I put a few
services like you can say okay these are
my DC instances this is my GCS service
and you know this is my bigquery and
these are the services which should be
able to talk to each other by doing this
you ensure that your data cannot be
exfiltrated to any other service
additionally what you can also do is you
can say okay these are the on-prem IP
addresses which I am whitelisting right
so this extends the hybrid security
access patterns to the public cloud and
gives you your own firewall
so this is a very very strong security
primitive we are announcing private beta
for the pieces of his controls and we
invite you to test this feature and get
a chance to shape it as it goes into
production G right so last but not the
least today is the first time it gives
me a lot of joy that this is the first
time we are announcing bucket lock in
early access program for GCSE customers
so what bucket lock is is basically warm
storage right warm stands for write once
read many times it is also traditionally
classically called as retention lock
right so the use case is this say you
are a finance company you have to
conform to Finn Rice I see your cfdv
CFTC regulation or you are in movie
archive business or you are doing
general backup in archive and you need
to ensure that all your data has a
certain retention so once I write data
say your retention within these five
years and once you have said that
retention period during these five years
it should not be possible for anybody
including me
to delete this data or to modify this
data right warm storage is the solution
for this kind of a use case with GCS is
bucket lock it applies across all our
storage classes unlike other cloud
services out there is not just for our
cold a storage tier you can use bucket
lock across any storage tier in GCS and
you can use the same API so we are just
introducing two new operations one is
you know set retention policy the second
is lock the retention policy but that's
it you can use all the existing new
api's and in addition to you know the
basic fundamental warm capabilities we
are also supporting temporary hold an
event hold which are a little more
advanced features I will give you a
couple of small examples temporarily
hold example is say your company is
getting audited for two weeks or three
weeks right only during that time you
want to ensure that you have retention
log set that is your use case for
temporary hold and even based hold
example would be say you are a company
who's in the business of selling
mortgages all those so you want to let
the mortgage period or the
period play out and after that for FINRA
you still want to hold on to you know
that clients mortgage records for
another five years right so I would
invite all of you to test out this
feature as well and with that I would
invite my friend Frank to give you guys
a demo for these new features
thanks to position hi everyone I'm Frank
I am an engineer developer relations
that focuses on Google Cloud storage
developer experience today I will be
covering three special powers that
Google cloud platform provides you and
to give this demo context I'd like to
you to take a look at this slide so I'm
working with this fictional financial
institution they're the end they have a
credit card support team that has a chat
support vetch and those chat support
conversation logs are then stored into
Google Cloud storage okay so what this
context let's jump in can we switch to
the demo please thank you so the first
special power I want to talk about is
let's say that you or at least for this
for this demo we want to manage the
lifecycle of the encryption keys that
are used for the objects or the
conversations that are logged within
this bucket so what we're going to take
a look at first is customer magic
encryption keys to get started we need
to create a new KMS key so i'll to do
that we need to create a key so i'm
going to name it credit card support
team cue ring this will hold the key and
i'll select a location of you a central
one click create next i'll create the
key similar name support team key and
the rotation period is how often a new
version of this key is created I'll keep
these as default for now and click
create alright cool
so if we we have created a KMS key so
next we're gonna create our GCS bucket
using this key for customer match
encryption key so let's go over to the
Google Cloud Storage browser click
create look it so I'm gonna follow a
similar pattern
credit card support team lugs and I'm
going to select a regional location at
this time you must co-locate your kms
key ring and your GCS bucket so I'm also
going to select you a central one below
you'll notice that we've added a show
Advanced Settings we have by default
Google match keys but I'm gonna use
customer manage keys for this demo a new
drop-down shows up I can now select kms
key that I just created and a little
message pops up this tells me that GCS
does not have the necessary permissions
to act on our behalf to use this kms key
to encrypt and decrypt objects so I'm
going to give it the necessary
permissions by clicking grant ok and now
I can click create alright I'm going to
test upload a file to see how this all
works I have here a support team
conversation and I'm just going to
upload this all right over to the right
you'll notice that encryption type or
the encryption type is custom and manage
key and if you highlight over that it'll
tell you the information as to which key
is being used to encrypt this object so
over the lifecycle of your bucket even
if you change the kms key that you're
using you'll always know which key is
being used to encrypt which object ok so
with this special with the special power
one thing I like to recall is Raja I'm
mentioning about the pattern crypto
shredding so let's say that I need to
perform a lot of mass deletion of data
within a short period of time this
potentially could be a large task which
may take longer than the period of time
you have to delete this information but
now that we have customer manage keys
you can do this operation by just doing
a crypto shredder which effectively
destroys the kms key that's encrypting
these objects invalidating the data
that's in GCS so let's take a look at
how to do that let's go back to security
cryptographic keys
alright ok alright I know what to do do
this I'm gonna destroy all key version
material they'll start that and I need
to type this in copy/paste scheduled
destruction the first thing it does is
it disables the key from being used for
a future encryption or decryption and
the second thing it does is it schedules
it for Destruction and it takes about 24
hours for that key to be destroyed
ok let's go back to the GCS bucket
alright so now that we've the state of
we've disabled a key what we can now do
is I'll show you an example what happens
when you try to access that object again
so by accessing this object we see the
GCS is no no longer able to decrypt the
object so we'll show this mess error
message whenever you try to attempt to
access object it's a cloud KMS key is
disabled or destroyed ok so that's the
first special power moving on to the
second and the second special power all
right so let's say I want to keep these
conversations safe from being deleted by
accidentally or modified in any way the
next thing I'm going to talk about is
bucket lock here's I'm going to cover a
brief preview of the UI changes that are
coming to the storage browser in order
for you to set a retention policy for
your bucket as you can see we've there
will be a new tab for the retention
policy and I can now set a retention
policy within certain different units of
time I'm going to use seconds for the
sake of this demo and set it to 10
seconds
looks like two new lines come up locked
in on the lock state is unlocked so I
could still modify and remove this
retention policy and the effective time
is when this policy took effect let's go
over back to the objects and I'll try to
upload the same conversation how we did
before and I will try to delete it
before 10 seconds are up
all right cool so as you can see here
it's a forbidden that I can I cannot
delete this object at this time so
bucket lock has to remove the necessary
permissions that I need in order to
this object after 10 seconds or the
timeframe that you've set in this
retention policy you should be able to
delete it and you can automate this
process with life with object lifecycle
management if you do if you wish to do
so okay now the last thing I want to
cover is the last special power
so let's oh these conversations that are
held with this credit card support team
they need to verify the customer that
they're speaking with so there's most
likely PII in this conversation but in
for all intents and purposes you're most
likely going to or at least we're just
going to use use it for quality and
quality assurance just to make sure the
customer is happy and we don't eat that
PII to verify that that the customer is
happy so I'm gonna cover a DLP demo okay
so let's take a look at this this short
a little conversation here as you can
see it sits between a customer and a
cust customer support team member as I
scroll down some more you'll notice that
a lot more PII was provided than
necessary to verify the information or
verify this customer so we'd like to use
deal add a loss prevention API to go
ahead and redact this information so I'm
gonna click and chat which will then
start the process okay that happens
sometimes so I have this anyone okay so
you can see over to your right
it has redacted the PII from the
conversation which then can be stored in
GCS and as you can see it does it for
images as well okay with that can we
switch back to the slides please thank
you with that I would like to invite
Suresh back up to the stage to hear from
one of our partners thank you
[Applause]
so I invite all of you to participate
sorry yeah so with that I invite all of
you to participate in various stages of
testing whether is beta or early access
and and try out these features and get a
chance to shape how these features turn
out during their GA time with that I
would like to introduce my friend psy
who is from product management at Co ICT
who talk about his experiences of
partnering with Google Cloud storage and
also share with you
experiences from his own customers using
Google Cloud storage
thanks so much ish so first of all you
know thanks to the Google team for
extending an invite to be part of this
session really excited to be here so
like as like super she said I'm from
Kochi City I'm in the product management
team there and over the next several
minutes what I'm going to try and cover
is give you a little bit sense of you
know how Google Cloud storage and
cohesively partner together but more
importantly also talk about it in the
context of a real customer example in
terms of you know how they integrate
both cohesive and and GCS right so with
that just a quick background in terms of
what Kohi city is about SoCo he city is
a technology startup here right here in
Silicon Valley and with the mission of
redefining what we call a secondary
storage so if you look at just data in
general you have obviously your mission
critical primary environments but what
we see is there is a lot more growth in
what we refer to a secondary storage and
that refers to backup tests of disaster
recovery because of the fact that you
know for every primary data set there
are multiple copies of that data that
exists today with the incumbent
solutions so the first challenge that we
have with customers is in the aspect of
backup and recovery we just refer to as
data protection that's where the
cohesive Google partnership really comes
into play so what you see
is on the left we have the cohesive Data
Platform
as we call it which is a scale out
on-premise solution in this case that
can integrate seamlessly with Google
Cloud Storage with any class of Google
Cloud storage as a matter of fact
whether it's Regional multi-regional
near line and and cold line as well so
the idea here is with the data platform
that we have on-premise customers can
then you know easily set policies and
again everything that we do is policy
based API driven architecture so
customers can set policies to manage
their backups retention policies and
then you know extend it to leverage the
GCS offering for really long term
retention so what you see here is in
this example customers typically you
know backup the data on-premise and then
the policies will seamlessly move that
data into GCS and in this case Kohi city
manages that retention both on-premise
as well as in the in Google cloud right
to extend this a little bit we also have
an offering which we can run within the
GCP platform and we call that the
cohesive Data Platform trout addition so
like soba she alluded to you know more
and more workloads are also you know
born in the cloud these days right and
so backup data recovery and data
protection becomes a critical aspect of
it not only for your on-premise but also
within the workloads running in GCP so
that's where cloud Edition comes into
play so in a similar vein you can now
set up policies to backup your
infrastructure running in GCP on to the
cloud edition platform and that you know
cloud edition actually runs on the
compute infrastructure GCE it uses disks
persistent disks and then the GCS can be
an extension
of those persistent disks that that are
there in the in Google Cloud the
benefits to customers in general I would
say broadly you know three things one is
the simplicity and ease of use that we
bring to the table in terms of backup
and recovery the second is the
scalability of the solution so obviously
when we are talking the scale of GCP
then you know the offering that we have
is also it also needs to be scalable so
that's the second aspect of it the fact
that we can scale both on-premise as
well as in the cloud with more of a grow
sort of a pay-as-you-go model right as
your needs grow you can keep adding more
and more of the cohesive solution and
last but not the least is the security
right the fact that we encrypt we can in
leverage the encryption that Google
Offers and then when it's on-premise the
data is again encrypted and and
in-flight as well and then tying it in
with the VPC elements that supercedes
product so in order to do that let me
actually illustrate that with a real
customer example with one of our mutual
customers so this is a large
semiconductor manufacturer right here
actually in the in the Bay Area and
their use case is broadly twofold one is
they have they continue to have more of
a hybrid environment some on-premise as
well as new workloads in GCP and they
were looking for a data protection
offering that can do both right while
also leveraging GCS so what they started
off with is deploy the cohesive platform
on-premise and in fact they have grown
that over the last several months and
then for the long term retention send
the data on a policy based schedule to
Google Cloud Storage right so that's
where they started with as an extension
for their workloads running within GCP
they are now using our data platform
shroud edition in a V PC that's been
defined and the reason they leverage the
V PC and and I am concepts that Roger
talked about is they have several
different products projects within GCP
basically various different teams and
also acquisitions that have happened
over time resulting in a number of GCP
projects so they manage all this through
the V PC and I am roles and in the
backup recovery context I am roles are
even more significant because in terms
of you know managing just administrative
tasks you can have one role but in in
order to provide self-service capability
back to the end users you want them to
have the ability to recover their
virtual machines their files and so
there are various different roles
created in order to facilitate
self-service recovery as well so again
it ties in back to the V PC and I am
security constructs and the last element
I will add is we are also excited to be
you know a technology partner with
Google on the bucket lock aspect right
and this is something that not only this
customer is looking for but also several
of our mutual customers so we are
excited to be you know playing a role in
that and it directly ties in well with
again the retention use case now they
can not only manage the retention
aspects both within Kohi city as well as
GCS but customers can now leverage the
worm functionality to you know comply
with legal hold and other compliance
regulations so with that you know again
great to be here we have a booth here in
at next so please visit our booth for
more information and thanks for having a
super sheesh thanks I
so to conclude I would like to reiterate
that security is at the heart of our
design you can see it from the amount of
engineers we have dedicated to security
the amount of investment we do for
security the amount of cutting-edge
research papers which are coming out of
Google every year and the number of
custom silicones we are innovating every
year in the field of security to ensure
that your data is indeed safe with
Google right so security is something we
take very seriously as Diane mentioned
security is the number one worry for our
customers who are moving to public cloud
we want to ensure with Google it's not a
worry anymore we are as you as you
witnessed it in our session today we are
continuing to innovate and along with
all the special powers we have at this
point and all the new features we
continue to build we are giving you
every single tool and feature you need
to have systems which are secured by
design and default thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]